[Music]
the soldiers be indisposed three or five
in a house according to the number of
the family they were to assassinate had
their orders given them secretly they
had been all received as friends by
those poor people who intending no evil
themselves little suspected that their
guests were designed to be their
murderers at five o'clock in the morning
they began their bloody work surprised
and butchered 38 persons who had kindly
received them under their roofs McKean
himself was murdered and is much beyond
he was a stately well favored man and of
good courage and sense as also the Lord
Archon tricking a gentleman of more than
ordinary judgment and understanding who
has submitted to the government and had
Colonel Hills protection in his pocket
which he had got three months before I
cannot without horror represent how that
a boy about 8 years of age was murdered
he's seeing what was done to others in
the house with him in a terrible fright
run of the house and a spying captain
Campbell grasped him around the legs
crying for mercy and offering to be his
servant all his life I'm informed
captain Campbell inclined to spare him
but one Drummond an officer barbarously
run his dagger through him we're off he
died immediately the rehearsal of
several particulars and circumstances of
this tragical story makes it appear most
doleful as that McKean was killed as he
was drawing on his breeches standing
before his bed and giving orders to his
servants for the good entertainment of
those who murdered him while he was
speaking the words he was shot through
the head
and fell dead in his lady's arms who
through the grief of this and other bad
usages she met with died the next day it
is not to be omitted that most of those
poor people were killed when they were
asleep and none was allowed to pray to
God for mercy providence ordered it so
that the night was most boisterous so as
a party of 400 men who should have come
to the other end of the glen and began
the live work there at the same hour
intending that the poor inhabitants
should be enclosed and none of them
escaped could not March that length
until it was nine o'clock and this
afforded to many any opportunity of
escaping and none were killed but those
in whose houses Campbell of Glenwood
quartered otherwise all the mail under
seventy years of age to the number of
200 had been cut off before that was the
order and they might have easily been
executed especially considering that the
inhabitants had no arms at that time for
upon the first hearing that the soldiers
were coming to the Glen they had
conveyed them all out of the way for
though they relied on the promises which
were made them for their safety yet they
thought it not improbable that they
might be disarmed I know not whether to
impute it to the difficulty of
distinguishing the difference of a few
years or to the fury of the soldiers who
being once glutted with blood stand at
nothing that even from above seventy
years of age were destroyed they set all
the houses on fire drove off all the
cattle to the garrison of Inverlochy
nine hundred cows two hundred horses and
a great many sheep and goats and there
they were divided among the officers and
how dismal may you imagine the case of
the poor women and children was then it
was lamentable past expression their
husbands and fathers and nearest
relations were forced to flee for their
lives they themselves almost stripped
and nothing left them
and their houses being burned too not
one house nearer than six miles and to
get viduh they were to pass over
mountains and wreaths of snow in a
vehement storm we're in the greatest
parts of them perished through hunger
and cold it fills me with horror to
think of poor stripped children and
women some with child and some giving
suck wrestling against a storm in
mountains and heaps of snow and a length
to be overcome and give over and fall
down and die miserably
[Music]
you